erster oppositionsredner ist alexander
dobrindt der vorsitzende der
csu-landesgruppe
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin
sie haben dem tod von boris romanenko
gedacht ich möchte mich ausdrücklich
dafür bedanken für diesen würdigen akt
er steht stellvertretend für das leid
und den terror den in der ukraine gerade
die menschen erfahren verursacht durch
putin aber sein name steht auch für die
verantwortung deutschlands meine damen
und herren vor einer woche vier im
deutschen bundestag hat der präsident
sie lenski an die verantwortung des
deutschen bundestag und dieser regierung
appelliert ich danke dem bundesminister
christian lindner dass er auch dies hier
angesprochen hat aber letzte woche hat
die ampel ganz offensichtlich nicht die
kraft gehabt zur debatte im deutschen
bundestag das hat dem deutschen
bundestag in der summe geschadet und
deswegen sprachlosigkeit darf hier nie
wieder seinen platz haben
sie haben zu recht angesprochen dass
unser mitgefühl und unsere solidarität
dem folgt der ukraine gilt präsident sie
lenski hat letzte woche von einer neuen
mauer
gesprochen diese neue mauer ist durch
den zivilisationsbruch putins
hochgezogen es ist eine mauer zwischen
freiheit und unfreiheit und wir stehen
auf seiten der freiheit und die ukraine
braucht die chance auf der seite der
freiheit stehen bleiben zu dürfen
dazu braucht es aber nicht nur
solidarität sondern auch die chance zur
verteidigung und sehr geehrter herr
bundeskanzler es steht im raum dass die
bundesregierung die zugesagten
waffenlieferungen nicht einhält das
bundesverteidigungsministerium und das
bundeskanzleramt scheinen sich
gegenseitig die schuld zuzuschieben
herr bundeskanzler die bundesrepublik
deutschland liefern zu wenig sie liebe
zu langsam und sie will nicht darüber
reden klären sie was real ist und führen
sie das auch was wir gemeinsam
vereinbart haben nämlich die ukraine zur
verteidigung mit waffen zu versorgen
sehr geehrte
bundesfinanzminister
wir leben heute den zweiten haushalt den
sie dem deutschen bundestag vorstellen
einen dritten kündigen sie bereits an
mit ihrem ergänzungs haushalt bei dem
sie allerdings die inhalte heute auch
nicht vorstellen können und eine
grundgesetzänderung kündigen sie an die
sie selber nicht entscheiden können in
anbetracht dieser lage hätte ich mir von
ihnen etwas mehr demut und
bescheidenheit auch gewünscht
ihre bisherige bilanz heißt einen
verfassungswidrigen haushalt vorlegen
heute einen unvollständigen haushalt
nachliefern und eine grundgesetzänderung
an kündigt mit der rekordschulden in
deutschland gemacht werden dafür braucht
es sehr bescheidenen
entschuldigung aber weil sie dauern
zwischen rufen ich habe die rede sehr
genau zugehört und der ergänzungs
haushalt der hier angekündigt wird der
hat bisher noch überhaupt kein
inhaltlicher weise eine weitere
rekordverschuldung deswegen das was sie
heute hier vorgestellt haben das ist
kein haushalt zum beraten sondern ein
haushalts rätseln dass es zu erraten
gilt aber das ist zu wenig für den
deutschen bundestag
zu drei großen bereichen haben sie heute
der bundesfinanzminister nicht vorgelegt
zur finanzierung der verteidigung
fehlanzeige zur reduzierung der
energiepreise fehlanzeige
die herausforderungen der
flüchtlingssituation fehlanzeige
zum ersten verteidigung wir haben sehr
genau in erinnerung wie der
bundeskanzler in seiner rede am 27.2
positiv dieses haus überrascht hat war
dass sich klar zur erfüllung und
überfüllung des 2% nato ziels bekannter
der bundeskanzler ich habe ihm damals
gesagt das gilt auch heute bei diesem
ziel haben sie uns an ihrer seite aber
wir wurden heute negativ überrascht in
diesem haushalt findet sich von dem zwei
prozent ziel rein gar nichts im
gegenteil der haushaltstitel der
verteidigung wächst nicht mal auf er
bleibt auf jahre gleich herr
bundesfinanzminister wenn sie glauben
sie könnten das versprechen des
bundeskanzlers gegenüber dem deutschen
bundestag ab sofort das zwei prozent
ziel einzuhalten nur damit einlösen dass
sie 100 milliarden neue schulden
aufnehmen und ansonsten den
verteidigungshaushalt innovationen
inflationsbereinigt reduzieren dann
haben sie uns nicht an ihrer seite um
die es klar zu sagen
die 100 milliarden sondervermögen von
denen sie sprechen
das ist nichts anderes als 100
milliarden sondern schult um diesmal
sehr klar zu benennen sondern schulden
die sie über eine grundgesetzänderung
erreichen wollen dafür brauchen sie
unsere zustimmung und es ist schön dass
wir bereits diese woche mit ersten
gesprächen darüber beginnen aber ich
kann ihnen auch an der stelle nur sagen
100 milliarden neue sonder schulden ohne
festzuschreiben wie sie diese
zurückzahlen wollen das wird unsere
zustimmung nicht haben schuldentilgung
ist ein teil von solider
haushaltspolitik lassen sie sich das an
dieser stelle sagen
die gerade ihnen auch dringend der
bundesfinanzminister die ausgaben
debatte in der koalition unter kontrolle
zu bringen es war sehr interessant
festzustellen wie der applaus zu ihren
sehr klaren sätzen im plenum hier
verteilt ist wohlstand erst der
wirtschaften dann verteilen gratulation
für diese erkenntnis keine zustimmung
bei spd und begrünen magere applaus bei
der fdp ich hätte mir deutlich stärker
gewünscht an dieser stelle dass sie zum
ausdruck bringen diese 100 milliarden
neue schulden sie müssen ausdrücklich
für die landesverteidigung und die
bündnisverteidigung zur verfügung stehen
ausdrücklich für ausrüstung und
bewaffnung der bundeswehr
ausdrücklich für nukleare teilhabe und
der atomaren abschreckung für nichts
anderes steht dieses vermögen zur
verfügung für nichts anderes werden wir
die hand reichen und ich rate ich in der
zug in ihrer ampel dafür zu sorgen dass
die ganzen ausgabenwünsche nicht über
diese 100 milliarden finanziert werden
soll egal ob die minister außenpolitik
oder andere ideen sie haben dieses geld
steht für verteidigung
bündnisverteidigung zur verfügung für
die bundeswehr aus nichts anderes
zu halten wir haben über die
energiepreise
gesprochen der bundesfinanzminister sie
hätten heute die gelegenheit gehabt ihr
konzept vorzustellen wie sie auf die
explodierenden energiepreise reagieren
es reicht einfach nicht zu erklären dass
die energiepreise zum neuen sozialen
frage werden es ist ganz konkret tendler
familien im ländlichen raum bezahlen an
der tankstelle 200 300 400 euro mehr pro
monat dafür hat die ampeln
offensichtlich keine lösung und ich kann
ihnen sagen die menschen können es sich
schlichtweg nicht leisten dass sie
zwischen den parteien in der ampel
gerade streiten und ich sage ihnen es
ist auch vollkommen egal ob das der fdp
tank rabatt ist oder das grüne
tempolimit beides ist falsch setzen sie
doch auch die marktwirtschaft und nicht
auf die zettelwirtschaft wir können es
uns nicht weiter leisten an der
zapfsäule licht zu handeln
sie verweigern sogar die erkenntnis dass
sie an der zapfsäule kräftig
mitverdienen ich gerade ihnen geben sie
den menschen ihr geld zurück die
mehrwertsteuer hat sich an der zapfsäule
seit vor coroner zeiten um 70 prozent
gesteigert wenn die steuern zu hoch sind
wusste die fdp früher was zu tun ist
kommen sie denn endlich nach senken sie
die steuern an der zapfsäule es geht um
die mehrwertsteuer es geht um die
mineralölsteuer und kommen sie mir nicht
mit dem europarecht die polen haben die
bilder steuer an der stelle gesenkt es
hat sich in europa niemand berührt und
der europäische rat für dem zustimmung
nach wende
[Applaus]
ein bisschen sehen
das was viele länder machen
und das was von europa licht gerückt
wird ist
erkennbar im sinne unserer gemeinschaft
und ich rate ihnen dringend es ist
klüger die steuern an der zapfsäule zu
senken als umgehungs tatbestände zu
schauen zu schaffen die dann wirkungslos
sind in der sache und die menschen nicht
entlassen hatte damals der kalkulierte
kommen sie zum ende oder dann würden wir
bei den anderen was
vielen dank für den hinweis
dritter punkt sie haben über die
aufnahme der flüchtlinge gesprochen eine
historische
kraftanstrengung mit erheblichste
auswirkungen auf unseren haushalt
deswegen sagen sie der ergänzungs
haushalt wird sich ausschließlich mit
der situation und dem krieg in der
ukraine und den herausforderungen daraus
beschäftigen wir werden das sehr genau
beobachten ich kann ihnen aber auch
sagen dazu gehört neben den finanzen
auch eine gute organisation
da lässt es an allen stellen bisher
missen es funktioniert keine
registrierung der menschen die auf
flucht sind in deutschland wir haben uns
die situation in polen ganz genau
angesehen da wird registriert der wird
aufgenommen er wird dafür gesorgt dass
die menschen in einem datensatz
zusammengeführt sind und man weiß wo sie
sich befinden in deutschland scheint das
nicht zu schaffen zu sein und die
bundesinnenminister in sagt an der
stelle niemand hat eine glaskugel und
weiß was noch auf uns zukommt war
braucht an dieser stelle keine glaskugel
sondern lediglich einen blick auf die
grenzen hunderttausend menschen die
jeden tag über die grenze nach polen
kommen da weiß man was deutschland was
auf deutschland zukommen deswegen
engagieren sie sich bitte sorgen sie
dafür dass endlich registriert wird das
endlich dafür gesorgt wird dass wir auch
zukünftig damit dann in europa ein
verteilungsmechanismen mechanismus
organisieren können ohne
verteilungsmechanismus ohne
registrierung werden erheblich mehr
finanzielle lasten auf uns zukommen als
notwendig ist weil wir die
solidargemeinschaft in europa nicht
nutzen können das ist die realität
und ich will ihnen sagen an dieser
stelle
der bundesfinanzminister sie haben von
einem signal
nach europa gesprochen genau dieses
signal nach europa
bereitet mir große sorgen sie haben von
einem signal der solidität gesprochen
ich glaube in europa wird ein signal
ankommen wie man sondern schulden machen
kann und deswegen rate ich ihnen sehr
dringend ich rate ihnen sehr dringend
geben sie darauf achten dass nicht die
wichtigste ressource
deutschlands in europa
verloren geht nämlich die
berechenbarkeit und die solidität im
finanziellen handeln das steht auch ein
spiel und mit ihrem namen verbunden
herzlichen dank
alexander dobrindt
[Musik]
landesgruppen vorsitzender der csu im
deutschen bundestag hat hier
geschmeidige drei minuten überzogen
seien ursprünglich geplanter höhe zeit
das wird so hat es hier
bundestags-vizepräsidentin
göring-eckardt schon angekündigt zu
lasten der weiteren unions geben ergeben
was hat der reklame fehlende
informationen zum thema zum thema
flüchtlinge und zum thema energiepreise
nächster redner dennis rohde
haushaltspolitischer sprecher der spd
fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wie er hat mit blick auf diesen
haushalt glaube ich alle die hoffnung
dass die planungsunsicherheit dem
unterliegen kleiner werden aber zur
wahrheit gehört die
inflationsprognosen sind noch nie so
weit auseinander gegangen in der
wissenschaft die wachstumsprognosen sind
noch nie so weit auseinander gegangen
die folgen der korona krise müssen sich
mit den folgen des völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskriegen der russen auf die
ukraine in zeiten wo die energiepreise
explodieren
menschen dadurch von ihren
teilhabemöglichkeiten
bedroht werden ausgeschlossen zu werden
wo menschen schutz und zuflucht bei uns
suchen wo die friedensordnung der
letzten drei jahrzehnte endet stellt uns
das nicht nur vor allgemein politische
herausforderung sondern auch vor
haushalterische herausforderungen des
der moment einmal innezuhalten und die
maxime der eigenen haushalts politik zu
überdenken liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und deshalb
und deshalb ist es gut und ist es
richtig dass die bundesregierung jetzt
weiter plant und dass der
bundesfinanzminister angekündigt hat ein
ergänzungsbau halt zu diesen themen
vorzulegen um die großen
herausforderungen die davor und stehen
auch anzugehen und ich will für unsere
fraktion sagen für uns ist haushalts
politik kein selbstzweck es geht nicht
darum ob die mk am ende höher oder
niedriger ausfällt ob die ausgaben
steigen oder sinken ob die
investitionsquote so oder so ist all das
ist kein zweck an sich das ist kein wert
an sich es geht nicht um das blinde
erreichen gegen welche kennzahlen für
uns geht es darum dass der staat gerade
in diesen krisenzeiten in der lage ist
sicherheit im wandel zu geben das ist
das ist unser verständnis von der
aufgabe eines vorsorgenden und
fürsorgenden staates und das ist die
maxime unserer haushaltspolitik und eine
zentrale rolle bei der bekämpfung der
herausforderung die phorms liegen bitter
klima und transformations- vorhaben der
wert erheblich ausgestattet werden 203
milliarden euro bis 20 26 geld was in
jederlei hinsicht wichtig ist weil
allein dieser klima und transformations-
fonds zur bekämpfung aller drei krisen
wichtig ist die uns bevorstehen er ist
wichtig zur bekämpfung der klimakrise
über die wir in diesen zeiten vielleicht
viel zu wenig diskutieren aber es ist
unsere pflicht dem planeten für künftige
generationen zu sichern und dafür ist
der klima und transformationsländer
wir wollen
wir wollen mit den maßnahmen aus dem
klima- und transformations- von der
wirtschaft bei ihren so notwendig
wichtigen transformationsprozessen
helfen sei es in der stahl- oder in der
chemieindustrie wir wollen aber auch
menschen helfen ihren persönlichen
beitrag zur energiewende zu leisten
indem sie zum beispiel zuschüsse für die
energetische sanierung ihrer häuser
bekommen auch das ist uns wichtig und
trainer der klima und transformation
zwar ergibt auch antwort auf die zweite
krise über die wir momentan sehr viel
diskutieren nämlich auf die folgen der
ukraine krise es geht uns darum und ich
glaube der letzte in diesem haus muss es
jetzt auch verstanden haben durch den
ausbau der erneuerbare energien
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
sicherzustellen und unabhängig zu werden
von drittstaaten das ist das ziel was
wir jetzt die wir angehen wollen und
deshalb ist der klima und transformation
zwar auch an der stelle so wichtig liebe
kolleginnen und
all das ist auch verbunden mit der
pandemie bewältigung jeden euro den wir
investieren schafft arbeitsplätze
er sorgt dafür dass die arbeitsplätze
die wir in den letzten zwei jahren durch
diese krise geführt haben morgen zukunft
zum gesellschaftsfähig sind er sorgt
dafür dass die brücken die wir gebaut
haben in der zukunft ankommen wir werden
mit dem energie und klimafonds mit dem
klima und transformations- von diese
pandemie nachhaltig verlassen und das
ist auch politisch wichtig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
nun sind die verhandlungen die wir in
den nächsten monaten führen werden
wesentlich umfangreicher als das was du
sonst halten wir werden den kernhaushalt
der uns vorgelegt wurde diskutieren wir
werden den ergänzungs haushalt
diskutieren der uns hoffentlich in
wenigen wochen vorliegt wir werden das
gesetz diskutieren was den energie und
klimafonds zum klima und
transformations- vormacht und wir werden
über eine grundgesetzänderung und über
das sondervermögen der bundeswehr
diskutieren ich glaube einen hier ist
der
ausstattungs zustand der bundeswehr
bekannt die bundeswehr hat drei
jahrzehnte friedensdividende gezahlt
herzige zeit weil für viele von uns hier
auch nicht vorstellbar dass wir heute
wieder in dieser situation sind in der
wir uns befinden für meine generation
ich bin
1986 geboren für viele kolleginnen und
kollegen hier im haus die noch jünger
sind den kalten krieg nicht mehr aus
eigenem erleben wahrgenommen haben ist
das gerade wahrlich eine zeitenwende und
deswegen begrüßen wir die initiative des
bundeskanzlers ein sondervermögen zur
stärkung der bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit zu schaffen
ausdrücklich liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich will aber
will aber herr kollege drin sagen wenn
man mit blick auf das sondervermögen nur
über schulden spricht dann frage ich
welches bild sollen die soldatinnen und
soldaten in deutschland eigentlich noch
von dieser unionsfraktion haben
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass wir
eine breite akzeptanz für diese
sondervermögen in der bevölkerung haben
weil es eben durch seine ausgestaltung
dafür sorgt dass die themen der äußeren
sicherheit nicht in konkurrenz gestellt
werden zu den themen der inneren und der
sozialen sicherheit dass wir nicht das
eine gegen das andere ausspielen sondern
dass wir die krisenfolgen ganzheitlich
betrachten äußere innere und soziale
sicherheit stärken und das ist gerade in
der heutigen zeit eine wichtige
botschaft liebe kollegen umzulegen
und frau ministerin lambrecht
ich begrüße dass es nicht nur um die
finanzierung von prestigeträchtigen
großprojekten geht das ist nicht nur
darum geht eine nachfolge für den
tornado zu finden und schweren
transporthubschrauber sondern dass sie
von vornherein deutlich gemacht haben
ein teil dieses geldes ist dafür da um
die soldatinnen und soldaten ganz
schnell persönlich besser auszustatten
geld was sofort bei der truppe ankommt
und das ist auch ein wichtiges signal
was wir glaube ich alle unterstützen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
gerade gesagt dass mir die äußeren nicht
gegen die innere und die soziale
sicherheit aus spielen und ich will ein
beispiel nennen wo es glaube ich jetzt
mit blick auf den ergänzungs haushalt
auch drauf ankommt wir reden in dieser
kriegerischen situation mit blick auf
die ukraine über unsere verantwortung in
der welt wir reden darüber den die
menschen die dort schutz suchen zu
helfen hier bei uns oder anderswo aber
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass es nicht
nur die ukraine gibt wir reden auch über
afghanistan über syrien somalia über den
jemen den irak ich könnte noch viele
weitere länder aufzählen wie dürfen wir
in dieser debatte nicht vergessen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen um es
[Applaus]
ganz deutlich zu machen wenn wir gerade
lesen dass die ukrainische
getreideproduktion wegbricht dass das
bei uns dafür sorgt dass preise steigen
werden wir uns das aber leisten können
das ist aber droht das dadurch in afrika
eine hungersnot ausgelöst wird dann
dürfen wir nicht weggucken liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und da muss
müssen wir einen beitrag dafür leisten
den zu helfen und auch das muss sich im
ergänzungs haushalt wiederfinden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
bundeskanzler hat von einer zeitenwende
gesprochen vieles um uns herum befindet
sich im wandel für uns das ist aufgabe
einer vorausschauenden haushaltspolitik
im sicherheit in diesem wandel zu geben
und darum werde dafür werden wir uns in
den nächsten wochen in den
haushaltsverhandlungen einsetzen vielen
dank
denn es wurde haushaltspolitische
sprecher der spd fraktion in der
aussprache zum bundeshaushalt 20
22 wir sind in der sogenannten
allgemeinen finanzdebatte und nachdem
der bundesfinanzminister sein etat hier
vorgestellt hatte nächster redner peter
böhringer aus der fdp-fraktion da ist
der haushaltspolitischer sprecher jan
den wortreich gehört dass haushalterisch
diesmal alles anders ist dabei ist im
haushaltsentwurf noch fast gar nichts
angekommen vom krieg den die zugehörigen
kostenposition will mir erst im rahmen
eines ergänzungs haushalts einbringen
und die erwartbaren kreditermächtigungen
über am ende wahrscheinlich 250
milliarden euro werden auch nur zu einem
kleinen teil kriegs folgekosten
finanzieren der kanzler sprach am 27
februar hier von einer zeitenwende nun
haushalterisch hat diese bereits 2020
stattgefunden die ausnahme situation
wird nun heute hier bereits im fünften
haushalt beschworen natürlich war der
krieg nicht vorhersehbar aber
haushalterisch wird er nun als haus
rhede genutzt genau wie seit 2020 corona
der ausnahmezustand wird die normalität
sein wir werden ab jetzt immer im
ausnahmezustand sein dieses unglaubliche
zitat von bundes- krankheits minister
lauterbach gilt offenbar auch hier
der vorgelegte haushalt ist erneut
verfassungsrechtlich bedenklich wie
schon vier corona haushalte zuvor
vielleicht denkt die bundesregierung
dass es irgendwann keiner mehr merkt
wenn man sich nur lange genug über das
grundgesetz hinwegsetzen
eine außergewöhnliche notlage liegt den
omikron zeiten nicht ansatzweise vor die
mit dem haushalt finanzierten maßnahmen
stehen vielfach nicht im zusammenhang
mit der behaupteten corona notlage und
erneut werden kredite aufgenommen
anstatt die bestehende sehr große asyl
rücklage aufzulösen
völlig verschollen ist übrigens die von
nicht einmal acht wochen durch die union
ganz großspurig angekündigte
verfassungsklage gegen den haushalt 21
am 27 januar klang es bei der cdu csu
noch so herr bremen herr hase am
mittelberg auch herr dobrindt eben
verfassungswidrig wir werden ihnen das
nicht durchgehen lassen unmittelbar nach
veröffentlichung werden wir im
eilverfahren klage beim
verfassungsgericht einreichen das war
ein zitat das war vor acht wochen bis
heute wurde nichts von einer solchen
klage bekannt obwohl die union ganz
alleine das quorum für eine
normenkontrollklage hätte obwohl sie
sich nur unsere entsprechenden anträge
seit 2020 zu eigen machen müsste liebe
union wenn sie noch unterstützung
brauchen wir sind weiterhin gerne
behilflich
[Applaus]
wir hoffen ja sehr dass sie sich bei
ihrer klage ankündigung nicht um eine
reine politshow gehandelt hat oder hat
man vor dem gesetz oder vor dem gang
nach karlsruhe noch gemerkt dass man bei
einer klage faktisch gegen das eigene
langjährige vorgehen der union im
angeblichen corona notzustand klagen
würde ja so holen einen eben die sünden
der vergangenheit ein die einzige
rechtsstaatliche opposition ist auch im
haushalt irischen nur die afd
die haushalts begründung auch heute ist
wiederum unehrlich die bundeswehr
milliarden haben gar nichts mit dem
ukraine krieg zu tun mit ihnen wird
einfach nur der seit jahren bestehenden
investitionsstau aufgelöst
es findet also derselbe
etikettenschwindel wie schon bei der
chor oder neuverschuldung oder beim eu
corona programm next generation statt
über eine billion wurde dort praktisch
überall und für alles ausgegeben nur
nicht in deutschland und auch nicht
gegen korona
und auch die steigerungen der
energiekosten waren bereits lange vor
dem krieg im markt schon im januar lagen
unsere energie ein vorkosten um
144 prozent höher als im vorjahr strom
war sogar um 212 prozent teurer als 20
21 was in erster linie politik bedingt
war stichwort co2 abgaben auch das sind
keine kriegsfolgen als erzählen sie das
nicht wenn sie den ergänzungs haushalt
vorlegen minister lindner die teuerung
hat uralte hausgemachte ideologische
ursachen die schulden die ezb
gelddruckerei die co2 ideologie und eben
die carola maßnahmen alles schon vor dem
krieg tag
insgesamt wird der bund zwischen 20 22
und 20 und 22 so viele schulden
aufnehmen wie in den 25 jahren bis 2019
kumuliert zuvor und der regierung
profitiert sogar indirekt von dieser
entschuldung durch inflation und durch
inflationsbedingte steuermehreinnahmen
der haushalt ist auch unzureichend in
bezug auf die von der fdp jahrelang
angekündigten entlastung der bürger wir
finden einige homöopathische
entlastungen und erleichterungen beim
arbeitnehmer pauschbetrag beim
grundfreibetrag und bei der anhebung der
entfernungspauschale jedoch nicht
ansatzweise die inflations verluste
ausgleichen werden dann ist es ja sie
haben ja eben fünfjahres einsparungen
kumuliert aufgezählt auch die sogenannte
abschaffung der eeg umlage auf das haben
wir eben gehört ist lediglich eine
umschichtung von etwa 25 milliarden
heraus aus der stromrechnung hinein in
den bundeshaushalt das ist keine
entlastung der bürger sondern eine
umetikettierung und ein verstecken
dieser gewaltigen position der preis der
energiewende verschwindet aus der
stromrechnung wohin jeder sehen kann die
belastung jedoch bleibt wie war das noch
bisher mit all den transparenz
forderungen gerade der fdp
der haushalt ist geradezu
anachronistisch oder die krone ausgaben
nicht nur fort schreibt sondern in
zeiten leerer krankenhäuser und sehr
lehrer intensivstationen skandalöser
weise sogar noch erhöht
27 milliarden an corona mehrbelastung
gegenüber dem ersten regierungsentwurf
erneut auf punkt und erneut in weiten
teilen nicht für medizinische zwecke
verwendet
moderieren sie endlich die pandemie ab
sämtliche maßnahmen und alle damit
zusammenhängenden kosten für impfungen
oder masken beschaffung oder gar völlig
absurde impfserum es einkäufe bis
2029 müssen sofort enden
im ergebnis die planwirtschaft über
schulden finanzierte staatsausgaben und
eine dadurch immer höhere staatsquote
schreiten auch unter ampel führung in
deutschland und europa munter voran nur
die euro kritiker und
stabilitätspolitiker der afg warnen seit
vielen jahrzehnten vor den folgen des
gelddruckens und der
realitätsverweigerung auf allen ebenen
nun sind sie halt da angesagt
dieter böhringer für die fraktion in der
letzten legislaturperiode war er sogar
vorsitzender im haushaltsausschuss jetzt
sven christian kindler aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen und der insel
haushaltspolitischer sprecher angesehen
nach wie vor in der allgemeinen debatte
zum bundeshaushalt 20 22 präsidentin
meine damen und herren wir beraten heute
den ersten haushaltsentwurf dieser neuen
regierung mit extremen bedingungen wir
sind mit mehreren krisen gleichzeitig
konfrontiert das ist die klimakrise die
immer noch anhält und weiter eskaliert
die korona pandemie noch nicht lange
vorbei ist und das ist seit dem 24
februar leiter der schreckliche
angriffskrieg von wladimir putin gegen
so kleine
und diese krisen haben verdammt wurde
hinwiesen noch massive auswirkungen auf
diesen hausdorf kommende haushalte und
wir sagen sehr klar im bundestag aus
koalition wir werden diese
herausforderung angehen dafür wurden wir
gebeten deutschen bundestag dafür stehen
dass koalition zusammen wir nehmen
diesen auftrag an für die
haushaltsberatung
[Applaus]
und dieser aus entwurf ist eine gute
grundlage für die parlamentarischen
beratungen jetzt kommen viele wichtige
maßnahmen ihr verankert waren
klimaschutz bei energiepolitischen
maßnahmen bei sozialen maßnahmen weil
wirtschaftliche maßnahmen
entlastungsmaßnahmen die alle schon
etatisiert sind und natürlich ist es in
dieser lage völlig klar dass noch nicht
alles in dieser hoch dynamischen lagen
so am entwurf enthalten sein kann es hat
übrigens auch adobe und die union im
haushaltsausschuss gar nicht kritisiert
und übrigens hat auch die union zusammen
mit der spd 2020 im laufenden
haushaltsjahr waren ergänzungs haushalt
vorgelegt also es kein neues erfahren
dass wir erkennen ich wünsche mir mehr
demut von der union wenn es um
verfahrensfragen außerhalb gehen
und mit diesen bitteren zeiten wo wir so
viele mehrere krisen gleichzeitig
erleben ist es zentral dass der staat
die menschen diesen mit diesen folgen
dieser krise nicht alleine lässt die
zeiten in denen sich in krisen
regierungen zurücklehnen und hoffen dass
irgendwie alles vorbei geht die sind
vorbei das prinzip too little too late
hat ausgesorgt dadurch wurden
krisenverschärfend sowie eben größer
gemacht was wir jetzt brauchen ist
aktives staatliches handeln in krisen
gelassen die menschen in deutschland
europa mit diesen folgen nicht allein
und es wird auch nicht am geld scheitern
[Applaus]
und klar ist auch wir müssen jetzt
natürlich auch energiepolitisch deutlich
vorankommen die zeitenwende heißt auch
für uns wir müssen deutlich unabhängiger
werden von gas öl und kohle
wir haben eine riesige aufgabe vor uns
wir sagen sehr klar nationale sicherheit
ist auch energiesicherheit wir haben in
diesem haushalt jetzt zentrale
öffentliche investitionen
festgeschrieben wenn man sich den
gesamten haushalt anguckt den
öffentlichen haushalt im kernhaushalt
plus die sonderflüge für digitales und
den energie und klimafonds kommen wir
auf 74 milliarden öffentliche
investitionen insgesamt sei ein
rekordwert und ein großer teil davon
sind klimaschutzinvestitionen und
investitionen für die transformation und
deswegen sagen wir sehr deutlich wir
können jetzt nicht stehen bleiben wir
haben diesen haushaltsentwurf aber wir
müssen natürlich auf die neuen situation
mit dem krieg nur klein reagieren also
energieeffizienz erneuerbare energien
grüner wasserstoff alles das ist jetzt
in den zentralen nächsten jahren
notwendig um uns unabhängiger machen und
sicherer zu machen und mehr klimaschutz
zu machen für die nachfolgende
generation
und klar ist auch wir werden diese
folgen auch finanzpolitisch bewältigen
werden müssen und sozialpolitisch
abfedern für die menschen in deutschland
aufgrund forcieren preissteigerungen und
von preissteigerung über lebensmitteln
und diese koalition hat ein erstes
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
zb mit dem heizkosten zuschlag mit dem
kinder sofort zuschlag und ich erwarte
dass wir zeiten ein zweites
entlastungspaket als koalition
beschließen werden und für unsere
fraktion ist sehr klar wir wollen dass
dieses paket sozial gerecht ist das
waren die management keinen kleinen oder
mittleren einkommen profitieren nicht
primär besserverdienende wir wollen dass
es anreize gibt zweitens für
energieeffizienz und energieeinsparungen
und drittens muss es zielgerichtet sein
ist in dem den menschen ankommen die es
jetzt wirklich brauchen und zwar am ende
auch nicht die renditen von mineral
konzern erhöhen dass am ende auch nicht
sein
und ich wundere mich schon etwas über
die finanzpolitische solidität der union
einerseits harte
absage an neue kredite gleichzeitig
zweistellige steuersenkungen dauerhaft
zu fordern und dann noch herr dobrindt
wie sie es gemacht habe ich sie gar
nicht mehr sind schon ganz mit da das
irgendwie auch nicht nett adobe und
leute sie eigentlich ansprechen weil sie
haben gesagt dass sie eine
mehrwertsteuersenkung bei den brit
spritpreisen fordern sie sogar ein
spritpreis bremse muss hier noch mal
sehr klar zu sagen das ist
europarechtswidrig eine bundesregierung
darf nicht europa recht breche ich weiß
dass sie eine vergangenheit als csu das
anders gemacht und ich inneren die maut
an das motto pakets über diese regierung
wird hier nicht europarechts flächen bei
der frage
eigentlich wäre auch noch mal daran
erinnern dass es 16 jahre lang
verteidigungsministerin und minister von
union waren von cdu/csu die dazu geführt
hat lässt die bundeswehr an diesem
zustand in ist indem sie ist und jetzt
haben wir einen klaren vorschlag des
kabinetts für die bündnispartner jungs
fähigkeiten einem sondervermögen und wir
haben sehr klar gesagt auch das ist ein
vermögen was für wichtige
investitionsvorhaben der bundeswehr
dient aber wir wollen auch klar dass es
effizient eingesetzt wird dass wir ein
hartes controlling brauchen wir brauchen
dafür strukturreform damit das geld
wirksam eingesetzt wird und nicht weiter
verbrannt wird und zweitens will ich
sagen gibt es auch ein begriff der
vernetzten sicherheit in diese
bundesregierung entwickelt hat und
weiter entwickeln wird zivile
krisenprävention die frage von cyber
sicherheit auch im inland zivilpartei
die massen alle zentralen
sicherheitsbereiche die wir auch konkret
finanzieren müssen wir weitere
erweiterten sicherheitsbegriff und kein
abrutschen sicherheitsbegriff so die
union
wir werden einen konkreten wir werden
sehr arbeitsreiche
haushaltsverhandlungen haben mit dem
ergänzungs haushalt mit dem
sondervermögen mit dem parlamentarischen
beratung wir werden hier sehr intensiv
im bundestag um mit der regen sagt
kommunalen und ich freue mich auf die
fahndung vielen dank
wenn christian kindler gerade jetzt in
teilen sie haben vielleicht so ist dann
im hintergrund der bundestags-
vizepräsidentin geben
einmal darauf hin dass die
allgemeinverfügung der präsidentin
vorsieht dass die masken auf behalten
werden es sei denn man ist hier am
redepult oder am saalmikrofon oder ist
gerade amtierende präsidentin das sage
ich aus gründen und ich sage auch aus
gründen dass die bedeckung von mund und
nase gemeint ist es wird nicht besser
wird euch das man nur die nase bedeckt
und den mund offen lässt und
ich kannte die kollegin die das so
handhabt nicht persönlich ansprechen
damit ihr name ist schon wieder ein
protokoll erscheint aber sie weiß sicher
wer gemeint ist herzlichen dank und ich
gebe das wort der kollegin dr gesine
lötzsch für die linke
gar nichts sagen und ich wollte sagen
dass sich katrin göring eckardt und
petra pau die sitzungsleitung es heute
noch einmal es
am pult vertretene position der
linksfraktion und haushaltspolitische
sprecherin es braucht einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand und putin muss die
russische armee abziehen und zwar sofort
meine damen und herren
der krieg in der unmittelbaren
nachbarschaft macht vielen menschen in
unserem land angst hinzu kommen
explodierende strompreise
klimakrise wohnungsnot und wachsende
altersarmut und auf all diese probleme
gibt die bundesregierung mit diesem
haushalt keine antwort und das ist
falsch meine damen und herren
für die bundesregierung ist die
aufrüstung der bundeswehr die aufrüstung
das wichtigste thema in den kommenden
vier jahren kanzlerschaft wird ein
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
auflegen und zur chefsache machen das
neue weg touristen soll ins grundgesetz
und damit verfassungsrang bekommen
dieser neuen rüstungsspirale wird meine
fraktion niemals zustimmen
soziale und ökologische fragen treten in
den hintergrund
kindergrundsicherung bürgergeld
ausreichende intensivbetten in den
krankenhäusern mehr pflegekräfte bessere
bildungschancen für unsere kinder sind
in ferne zukunft drückt und das ist
fatal und
auch die klimakrise und menschenrechte
sind nur noch ein lästiges randproblem
wenn der wirtschaftsminister bei
oligarchen in katar das einkaufen geht
vor kurzem haben die grünen noch
gefordert die
fußball-weltmeisterschaften wegen der
menschenrechtsverletzungen in katar
abzusagen jetzt ist es nur noch ein land
mit eigenheiten so geht das nicht meine
kolleginnen und kollegen
alle krisen treffen aber menschen
besonders brutal aber auch die
mittelschicht leidet unter dem
zunehmenden lasten wir brauchen nämlich
eine schnelle finanzierung aller der
menschen die eben nicht zu den wenigen
oligarchischen in unserer gesellschaft
gehören aber der finanzminister lindner
verteidigt starrsinnig die ökonomisch
unsinnige schuldenbremse aber für das
wettrüsten soll die schuldenbremse nicht
gelten da wird der turbo eingeschaltet
und das ist fatal die schuldenbremse
wird für soziale und ökologische fragen
gelten das heißt im klartext kürzungen
in der sozialpolitik das ist der falsche
weg meine damen und herren marcel
fritsche der chef des deutschen
instituts für wirtschaftsforschung hat
festgestellt es gibt kein land in dem
arbeit so hoch und vermögen so niedrig
besteuert werden wie deutschland das
wollen wir ändern milliardäre krisen und
kriegsgewinnler müssen endlich zur kasse
gebeten werden herzlichen dank
die liebe glück war dass die
haushaltspolitische sprecherin der
linksfraktion und da ist sie auch
stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende und das alles in
der debatte über den
debatte den hängen der allgemeinen
finanzdebatte so die kurse doch nochmal
gekriegt und jetzt ganz schnell weiter
mit christoph meyer
stellvertretender vorsitzender hälfte
die verzerren vor fast genau zwei jahren
hat der bundestag hier den ersten
nachtragshaushalt als reaktion auf die
korona pandemie beschlossen es wurden
vier nachträge der neuverschuldung des
bundes von
345 milliarden euro und ich bin froh
dass christian linder mit den jetzt
vorliegenden regierungsentwurf den
letzten pandemie haushalt vorlegt in den
letzten zwei jahren war ziemlich alles
die ausnahme nicht die norm die norm ist
finanzpolitische stabilität
nur sie
uns in die lage versetzt die
finanziellen herausforderungen in der
pandemie und auch jetzt die vor uns
liegen zu schultern
und das ist glaube ich auch klar dass
der regierungsentwurf nur ein abbild des
zustands vor dem ukrainer krieg sein
kann
die lage in europa hat sich ein weiteres
mal dramatisch geändert und es ist daher
richtig dass ein ergänzungs haushalt
vorgelegt wird und mein kollege sven
christian kindler zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass es doch klar ist dass
diese ergänzungs haushalt erst in den
nächsten wochen mit leben erfüllt werden
kann und zur demut herr dobrindt würde
auch dazu gehören das sie vor der menge
der herausforderung vor der wir stehen
das akzeptieren würden fällt auch
eingestehen würden das nicht
gleichzeitig mit dem ersten
regierungsentwurf dieser ergänzungs
haushalt hier vorgelegt werden kann
sondern dass es ein bisschen länger
dauern würde das wäre seriöse opposition
und nicht der klamauk den sie hier
gemacht haben
mit blick auf den regierungsentwurf
können wir festhalten dass die von der
vorgängerregierung geplante
nettokreditaufnahme von 99,7 milliarden
euro gehalten wurde und zwar trotz 25
milliarden euro mehrausgaben für die
bekämpfung der korona pandemie das ist
das verdienst von bundesfinanzminister
auf die strikte ausgabendisziplin hier
beharrt zu haben und das auch in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung so weiter
durchgehalten zu haben
all dies gelingt auch da christian
linder darauf hingewiesen obwohl wir
umfangreiche mittel zur verfügung
stellen um die aufgaben die wir uns in
den koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben
umzusetzen und anzuschieben der energie-
und klimafonds kriemann transformations-
form zukünftig wird 200 milliarden euro
bereitstellen um bis 2026 hier die
richtige schwerpunktsetzung zu
ermöglichen wir werden aber auch mit dem
haushalt
über das sondervermögen zur ertüchtigung
der bundeswehr sprechen und herr
dobrindt sie erinnern sich an die
regierungserklärung haben sie hier
formuliert ich erinnere mich daran wie
euphorisch beklatscht haben als der
bundeskanzler
die zwei prozent quote als zukünftiges
ziel ausgewiesen hat und langsam muss es
mir oder kommt mir der eindruck dass sie
von dieser euphorie ziemlich weit
mittlerweile weg sind und das hin und
her das hin und her was sie formulieren
wirkt offensichtlich eher so als ob sie
eher ein grund suchen warum sie diese
100 milliarden euro sondervermögen nicht
mittragen wollen warum sie die truppe im
regen stehen lassen wollen die letzten
16 jahre wo sie sie kaputt gespart haben
das basiert
maßgeblich entweder fan kurven
steckt ja und sie auch hier sind sie
auch wenn sie hier die wahrheit im
letzten wochen formuliert haben wenn sie
das was sie in letzten jahren formuliert
haben als union werden auch sie diesen
sondervermögen zustimmen müssen wenn sie
einen rest an glaubwürdigkeit als
oppositionsfraktion hier haben wollen
der krieg in europa die
veränderte sicherheitslage und die
folgen für wirtschaft und gesellschaft
werden die handlungsspielräume auch das
gehört dazu weiter begrenzen
steuererhöhungen hat unsere koalition
ausgeschlossen die schuldenbremse
versperrt richtigerweise die aufnahme
von übermäßigen schulden
und vor diesem hintergrund ist die
maßgabe des koalitionsvertrages ausgaben
auf den prüfstand zu stellen und zwar in
den nächsten jahren nicht im jahr 2022
genau der richtige weg nur durch
priorisierung von ausgaben werden wir
uns handlungsspielräume erweitern können
und dies ist umso wichtiger da parallel
natürlich die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unserer wirtschaft unserer gesellschaft
herausgefordert wird durch den ukraine
krieg wir werden wachstumsimpulse
schaffen müssen auch der
bundesfinanzminister darauf hingewiesen
und wir müssen uns vor allem darauf
verlassen auch das sind
koalitionsvertrag bereits angeregt dass
privates kapital
zukunftsinvestitionen sichern muss und
zwar als ergänzung zu den 200 milliarden
euro die wir staatlicherseits zur
verfügung stellen
handlungsspielräume von wirtschaft und
gesellschaft im angesichts der
finanziellen auswirkungen des krieges
sicherzustellen ist die aufgabe der
stunde es wurde bereits viel darüber
geredet wir haben ein erstes entlastungs
paket auf den weg gebracht und wir
werden jetzt über den ergänzungs
haushalt ein weiteres entlastungs paket
auf den weg bringen uns ist wichtig dass
dieses entlastungs paket schnell wirkt
zielgerichtet wirkt und nicht erst nach
monaten bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern
ankommt solide
solide finanzen wettbewerbsfähigkeit
sind die grundvoraussetzung für die
handlungsfähigkeit deutschlands in
krisenzeiten dass es oft betont worden
dieser haushalt schafft dafür genau die
richtige grundlage er ist schon sehr gut
wir werden ihnen sicherlich in den
beratungen noch ein wenig besser machen
ich freue mich darauf in den nächsten
wochen und danke für die aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
der kollege christian haase spricht
jetzt zu uns für die cdu/csu-fraktion
christian haase darf seine ganzen
geplanten acht minuten reden obwohl
alexander dobrindt worin mächtig
verzogen hat aber ein anderer
abgeordneter die chance rednerliste
rausgefallen der unionsfraktion nicht
gehabt ich wünschte ich hätte mich
geirrt war der ersten lesung zum zweiten
nachtragshaushalt 2021 am 16 dezember
habe ich hier an dieser stelle gesagt
dieser nachtragshaushalt ist der anfang
vom ende der schuldenbremse ich wünschte
es wäre anders gekommen für unser land
für die nachfolgenden generationen für
die stabilität der europäischen union
wäre eine solide und ehrlichen deutsche
finanzpolitik unglaublich wichtig
gewesen
leider ist das nicht der fall vor unser
aller augen erleben wir gerade das ende
der schuldenbremse mit jedem
erdenklichen trick versucht die
bundesregierung die schuldenregeln zu
umgehen wer dachte ein nachtragshaushalt
für einen abgelaufenen des haushalts
jahr und die rückwirkende buchungs
änderungen für sondervermögen wären
schon das ende der fahnenstange leider
falsch was das bundeskabinett am letzten
mittwoch beschlossen hat setzt dem
ganzen die krone auf da haben wir
erstens das 100 milliarden euro teure
sondervermögen bundeswehr da ist man
wenigstens ehrlich und verbindet die
umgehung der schuldenbremse mit einer
grundgesetzänderung
abseits von sicherheitspolitischen
fragen ist es finanz verfassungs und
europarechtlich natürlich eine
herausforderung wenn mittel in höhe
eines viertels eines normalen
gesamthaushaltes bei der berechnung der
zulässige neuverschuldung ausgeklammert
werden und wenn man damit meint jetzt
die blaupause für ähnliche aktionen zu
schaffen kann ich nur sagen nicht mit
uns
ja wir müssen die einsatzfähigkeit und
bereitschaft der bundeswehr verbessern
und ich danke dem kanzler für seine
kehrtwende und die klaren vorgaben für
die ampel nachdem er das in den letzten
jahren als finanzminister noch
erfolgreich verlangsamt hat es ist also
vor allem eine zeitwende für seine
partei meine damen und herren wenn wir
da jetzt aber einen gemeinsamen nenner
haben da muss das geld ausschließlich
für die bundeswehr verwendet werden
verlauf das sondervermögen nun alle
möglichen ressorts vom auswärtigen amt
über das innenministerium zugreifen weil
jeder teil der ampel etwas vom geld
haben will hat das weder was mit der
einsatzfähigkeit der bundeswehr zu tun
noch mit dem sinn eines sondervermögens
in der sondervermögen gehören die großen
rüstungs großen über jährigen
rüstungsprojekte und ist alles andere
gehört zur wahrung des budgetrechts des
parlamentes in den normalen haushalt
zweitens musste finanzminister lindner
bereits vor kabinettsbeschluss ein
ergänzungsbau hat ankündigen ein novum
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik so
werden im regierungsentwurf viele
positionen falsch oder sogar gar nicht
veranschlagt angefangen von zu hoch
geschätzten steuereinnahmen zu
optimistische arbeitsmarktzahlen bis zu
fehlenden ansätzen für das zweite
energie entlastungspaket möchten dieser
zwischenfragen von henrike 2009
anschließend dieser haushalt zerplatzt
so schnell wie eine seifenblase
zugegeben der angriff putin zwar nicht
zu erwarten aber entweder lichter
ergänzungs haushalt wir spätestens
anfang april vor und wir können darüber
sachgerecht diskutieren oder man lebt im
sommer einen nachtragshaushalt vor alles
andere konterkariert die rechte des
parlaments
drittens findet sich eine vielzahl von
weiteren bedenklichen manövern in diesem
haushaltsentwurf einziges ziel jeden
erdenklichen spielraum ausreizen die
tilgung der korona schulden verschiebt
sich klammheimlich von 2023 auf
2.028 und wird von 20 auf 31 jahre
verlängert anstatt bei ideologisch
motivierten projekten zu kürzen wird die
wir bei der rente gespart eine halbe
milliarde euro für die
rentenversicherung sind kurzerhand
entfallen viele ansätze beispielsweise
für kindergeld oder die geplanten super
abschreibungen sind viel zu niedrig beim
arbeitslosengeld 2 und bei den kosten
der unterkunft die regierung über vier
milliarden euro sparen das ist völlig
unrealistisch
die korona bedingten milliardenschwere
schieflage der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung wird komplett
ignoriert statt mehr haushaltswahrheit
mehr haushaltswahrheit wagen
verschleiert verschleiert täuscht und
tricks die ampel regierung wo es nur
geht und warum meine damen und herren
weil geld der einzige kitt ist der diese
koalition zusammenhält wo immer ein wo
immer ein problem auftaucht soll es mit
geld zugeschüttet werden dass es nicht
mehr zu sehen ist und aber ich bin
ehrlich da haben wir in den vergangenen
wahlperioden auch nicht immer stringent
gehandelt aber die haushaltssituation
war damals eine völlig andere wir haben
überschüsse gemacht und in eine rücklage
stecken können diese solide
finanzpolitik hat es uns dann erst
ermöglicht dass wir in der krise die
volkswirtschaft massiv stützen könnten
ja wir befinden uns in einer zeitenwende
so hat des bundeskanzlers richtigerweise
gesagt diese zeitenwende gilt aber auch
für die haushaltspolitik lieber
ampelkoalition ehren die zeit der
spielräume ist vorbei jetzt muss man
sich ehrlich machen prioritäten setzen
und das föderale finanzgefüge wieder in
ordnung bringen meine damen und herren
in dieser situation kann
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
einem wirklich leid tun wir alle kennen
ihn als überzeugten ordnungspolitiker
und ich kann mir vorstellen dass er
lieber die kleinen finanziellen
spielräume nutzen würde um die mitte der
gesellschaft zu entlasten
um in zeiten von krieg und pandemie die
wirtschaft vor einer rezession zu
bewahren und in zeiten der inflation die
kalte progression zu bekämpfen all das
wäre wirtschaftlich sinnvoll und ehrte
die unionsfraktion an seiner seite
stattdessen muss er lindner in einen
sauren grünen oder roten apfel nach dem
anderen weißen bei seinen reden hier an
diesem pult merkt man wie schwer es ihm
fällt diese ampel politik zu verkaufen
und
ganz ehrlich herr finanzminister
ich leide mit ihnen als bekannt wurde
dass die fdp und nicht die grünen das
bundesfinanzministerium erhalten da war
ich erleichtert
immerhin würde nun ein kühner
verteidiger der schuldenbremse das
ehrwürdige ministerium leiten dachte ich
stattdessen wird sich die
neuverschuldung in diesem jahr auf ein
neues rekordhoch bei ihren da sind die
100 milliarden im sondervermögen 100
milliarden im jetzt eingebrachten
haushalt und dazu kommen ich schätze mal
50 milliarden mit dem ergänzungs
haushalt 250 milliarden euro und ein
neuer schuldenrekord
und herr lindner weiß es wahrscheinlich
viel besser als die meisten anderen hier
im haus jetzt wäre eigentlich umfassende
aufgabenkritik angezeigt und gerade das
war ja immer ein kernanliegen der freien
demokraten von dem wir nichts mehr hören
man müsste knallhart priorisieren und
angesichts von pandemie krieg und
inflation ideologische projekte nach
hinten stellen da ist es ja gut wenn der
finanzwirtschaft zumindest das macht und
nach katar fährt aber verhandlungen das
hätte ich erwartet bitte mit katar auf
augenhöhe und nicht mit einem bückling
neuer finanzminister
die spd linke und der kollege kinder
haben die schuldenbremse bereits für
2023 abgeschrieben ich kann ihnen nur
sagen bleiben sie standhaft die
unionsfraktion wird an ihrer seite
stehen denn sie haben ja recht mit ihrer
ansage die schuldenbremse ist keine
frage des politischen willens sondern
eine frage der verfassung nur sollte man
nicht versuchen diese schuldenbremse mit
immer neuen sondervermögen zu umgehen
hier war er finanzminister ich weiß wie
gerne sie sagen würde lieber nicht
regieren als so falsch reagieren wie
jetzt
[Applaus]
der nächste christian haase war das der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der
unions-fraktion und aufrichtige momente
haben es verdient hervorgehoben zu
werden also wiederhole ich ansatz von
nie mehr wolle ehrlich sein hat er
gesagt auch wir haben mich immer
stringent gehandelt was den haushalt
angeht nächster redner er ist thorsten
rudolph aus der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister liebe kolleginnen
ein haushalt sind nicht nur zahlen ein
haushalt ist immer auch ein blick in die
zukunft
und manchmal auch ein blick tief in die
vergangenheit
ich möchte mit einem thema beginnen dass
einem das herz immer wieder schwer
werden lässt und dass uns der tod von
boris romanenko auch wieder erinnert hat
die wiedergutmachung für die opfer
nationalsozialistischen unrechts dieses
thema steht ganz am anfang des einzel
plans 08 aber auch ganz am anfang der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland
ich selbst weiß abteilungsleiter im
rheinland pfälzischen finanzministerium
eine zeit lang für die wiedergutmachung
zuständig und ich war seinerzeit in
saarburg im amt für wiedergutmachung
gewesen und habe mir dort die akten
zeigen lassen die geschichten der opfer
die sich in diesen akten finden sind
erschütternd es wird einem dort aber
auch sehr schnell eine besondere
ambivalenz bewusst
einerseits ist die wiedergutmachung
einer der historisch seltenen versuche
sich dem eigenen unrecht zu stellen
andererseits ist allein schon das wort
wiedergutmachung natürlich grundfalsch
es gibt keine wiedergutmachung
das wird einem dann ganz besonders
bewusst wenn man diese akten liest und
erfährt wie deutsche verwaltungsbeamte
die noch kurz zuvor oft selbst zu den
tätern gehörten dann in diesen
entschädigungsverfahren mit den opfern
umgegangen sind und sie nicht selten ein
zweites mal zu opfern gemacht haben
meine damen und herren es ist genau
diese ambivalenz die in die
gründungsjahre der bundesrepublik
deutschland eingeschrieben ist
seinerzeit aber übrigens die sonder
zuständigkeit für alle außer
europäischen fälle also auch für die
opfer die beispielsweise in israel und
den usa nun das ist auch der grund dafür
dass rheinland pfalz seit den 50er
jahren etwa ein drittel aller
entschädigungs fälle bearbeitet hat das
sind insgesamt rund eine millionen akten
saarburg ist damit international für
viele opfer eine art synonym für
wiedergutmachung geworden wir alle
wissen auch dass die letzten hoch
betagten zeitzeugen jetzt nach und nach
sterben aber das heißt nicht und das
möchte ich ausdrücklich hier im
deutschen bundestag von diesem pult
aussagen das heißt nicht dass die
aufgabe der wiedergutmachung damit in
irgendeiner form erledigt wäre
deshalb überaus dankbar dass das
bundesfinanzministerium unter dem
damaligen minister olaf scholz ein
großes projekt transformation der
wiedergutmachung gestartet und auch mit
entsprechenden haushaltsmittel unterlegt
hat es gab bereits ein großes
internationales symposion es wurde auch
bereits beschlossen alle
wiedergutmachungs akten zu
digitalisieren
ich begrüße es außerordentlich dass im
aktuellen haushaltsentwurf wieder rund
30 millionen euro für die folge aufgaben
der wiedergutmachung vorgesehen sind und
zusätzlich verpflichtungsermächtigung
von rund 50 millionen euro wenn aber
zugleich auch davon überzeugt dass die
digitalisierung die sagten nicht
ausreicht wir sollten ich würde mich
sehr freuen wenn sie diesen vorschlag
ernsthaft prüfen würden herr minister
wir sollten noch einen physischen ort
anbieten an dem die originalakten
einsehbar sind für die nachfahren der
opfer für die wissenschaft und für die
öffentlichkeit wir sollten ein solches
forschungs und dokumentationszentrum für
die geschichte der wiedergutmachung
einrichten bin überzeugt dass sage
dieser ort sein könnte wir sollten dies
im übrigen als bundesrepublik
deutschland auch für uns selbst tun wenn
wir rechenschaft darüber ablegen wollen
wer wir sind und wer wir sein wollen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe
zu beginn gesagt dass der haushalt auch
immer einen blick in die zukunft ist
insofern gibt es in diesem jahr
natürlich eine besonderheit weil gerade
auch das bemerkenswert ist das nicht im
haushalt steht und ich halte es in
vollem bewusstsein unserer schrecklichen
geschichte für richtig und wichtig dass
wir in anbetracht von putins brutalen
und menschenverachtenden
angriffskrieg 100 milliarden euro in
einem sondervermögen bereitstellen um
jetzt schnell die landes- und
bündnisfähigkeit zu stärken und unsere
zusagen gegenüber der nato finanziell zu
hinterlegen
wir sind aber vor allem zwei dinge
wichtig erstens dieses sondervermögen
stellt sicher dass wir die 100
milliarden euro nicht über den
kernhaushalt bereitstellen denn das
würde bedeuten dass wir unter geltung
der schuldenbremse an anderen stellen im
haushalt genauso massive kürzungen
vornehmen müssten und zweitens der
parlamentsvorbehalt wird umfassend
gewahrt es gibt hier keinen alleingang
der exekutive denn sowohl der
wirtschaftsplan des sondervermögens als
auch jeder einzelne beschaffung über 25
millionen euro müssen selbstverständlich
vom haushaltsausschuss genehmigt werden
neben diesen schwerpunkt sicherheit ist
aber genauso bemerkenswert was
tatsächlich im haushalt steht
sicherheit im wandel heißt eben auch
dass die koalition mit diesem haushalt
ihren äußerst ambitionierten
koalitionsvertrag mit leben erfüllt
dieser haushalt ist ein haushalt der
zukunftsinvestitionen dieser haushalt
wagt mehr fortschritt
der kernhaushalt alleine sieht
investitionen in höhe von rund 51
milliarden euro vor nur zum vergleich im
vorjahr 2009 10 waren es nicht einmal 39
milliarden euro dieser bundeshaushalt
2022 mitsamt der finanzplanung bis 2026
bedeutet mehr investitionen in den
sozialen wohnungsbau mehr investitionen
in bildung und forschung mehr
investitionen in verkehr und
digitalisierung
zusätzlich zu diesen investitionen im
kernhaushalt wird auch der energie- und
klimafonds erheblich besser ausgestattet
er wächst bis 2006 und zwei bis 2026 und
90 milliarden euro auf dann über 200
milliarden euro und das bedeutet massive
investitionen in die gebäudesanierung in
die elektromobilität und in den aufbau
einer wasserstoff-infrastruktur
all diese investitionen geben dazu dass
uns die große transformation gelingt
dass wir die gewaltigen
herausforderungen aus dekarbonisierung
digitalisierung und demographie meistern
und das inmitten eines umfeld das
geprägt ist von einer globalen pandemie
und einem völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg der die europäische
nachkriegsordnung zerstört hat deshalb
sind diese beiden punkte der sicherheit
und der zukunftsinvestitionen so eminent
wichtig und richtig und genau deshalb
ist dieser erste haushalt der
ampelkoalition klug
verantwortungsbewusst und
zukunftsorientiert mit einem wort die
bürger innen wissen was sie bei dieser
bundesregierung und den sie tragenden
parteien erwartet mit sicherheit
fortschritt
düsseldorfer was für die spd-fraktion
und er hat noch mal dass der 200
milliarden programmen für transformation
und klimaschutz hervorgehoben dass bis
20 26 dann ein effekte bringen soll
gottschalk ist der nächste redner sie
sehen ihn schon er ist der
finanzpolitische sprecher der fraktion
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen lasst uns das auf der
zunge zergehen 400 45,6 milliarden euro
nein das ist nicht die summe des
bundeshaushalt man könnte das vermuten
dass alleine ist die summe der
kreditaufnahmen für die jahre 2020 20 21
und 20 22 dazu kommen noch einmal 43,6
milliarden euro für die jahre 23 bis 26
wir reden hier also von knapp 490
milliarden euro einem fünftel der
öffentlichen staatsverschuldung einem
drittel der bundesschulden die sich hier
innerhalb von nur sechs jahren da sind
auch sie beteiligt meine damen und
herren der cdu csu hier auflaufen das
ist eine bankrotterklärung der deutschen
finanzpolitik euro rettungspolitik
südländer rettung ezb staatsschulden
tage zwei sein und inflation und nun
kommen wir zum endpunkt dieser
weichwährung genannt euro ihrer auf
hörfunk von staatsschulden der aus
unserer sicht verfassungswidrig ist uns
dieser tage genauso mitbeteiligt meine
damen und herren von der cdu/csu der
lindner ihr bekenntnis zur rückkehr zur
schwarzen null klingt da wie blanker
hass fini sie haben den ausnahmezustand
zum regelfall der finanz und
haushaltspolitik erklärt meine damen und
herren wollen sie wissen wenn sie denn
überhaupt noch zu hören was der bund der
steuerzahler
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
als ursache für die entstehung von
schulden sieht nicht etwa konjunktur der
krise sondern die gewählten politiker in
den parlamenten die über die einnahmen
und ausgaben des staates entscheiden
also sie werte kolleginnen und kollegen
der regierung tragenden fraktionen und
der 16 jahre davor kein corona kein
krieg sind ursache für diesen desolaten
zustand unseres landes meine damen und
herren
diese sind gewiss 3 war vielleicht auch
beschleuniger oder pendler aber
letztlich fördern sie nur viel schneller
das zutage was sie ein missmanagement in
diesem land in den letzten 16 jahren
betrieben haben ich erinnere an dieser
stelle noch einmal an den aus meiner
sicht verfassungswidrigen
nachtragshaushalt mein kollege böhringer
als getan indem kreditermächtigung für
corona mal so mir nichts dir liegt in
höhe von 60 milliarden euro für grüne
projekte und verwahrung wahrscheinlich
ihres koalitionsfrieden umetikettiert
wird sind dinge die sie sogar als fdp
fraktion in baden württemberg mit
verfassungsklage gelegt haben so
glaubwürdig sind sie noch hinten als sie
sind ein zwerg der glaubwürdigkeit
geworden
und reiner holznagel den ich hier mit
erlaubnis des präsident der präsident
der zitiere bringt es auf den punkt
allgemein sehe ich den trend dass starke
meinung immer häufiger eine sachgerechte
politik aushebeln dabei spielen lenkungs
und umverteilungs ambitionen meine damen
und herren von dieser koalition eine so
große rolle dass marktwirtschaftliche
grundprinzipien
ordnungspolitik systemkonformen reform
fast schon verwöhnt werden meine damen
und herren füge hinzu sie haben schon
längst moral über das recht gestellt und
das bedeutet recht rufen ohne ende und
am ende des tages das ende des
rechtsstaates wir als fdp sind die
einzige partei die für diese verfassung
und dem rechtsstaat noch eintritt
ja ihr politisches instrumentalisiert
das organ herr kollege da kommen wir
gleich dazu eigentlich müssten sie dort
vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet was
ihre haushalts qualität angeht
willkommen also in grün sozialismus und
die fdp herr lindner sie machen sich als
steigbügelhalter und diesen ausbruch
kann man wir brauchen für unsolide
staatsfinanzierung verdient bedienen
grün fast da fantastereien es schaffe
sie immer mehr eine gefahr für unseren
wohlstand
denn durch immer höhere steuern gerade
der energie feuern sie die inflation
weiter an wir stehen doch jetzt wahrlich
vor den frauen früchten meine damen und
herren die sie in verschiedenen
kombinationen auch unter frau merkel
anfing zu züchten und die durch die
aktuelle regierung weiter getragen
würden meine damen und herren die
deutsche verteidigungspolitik ist ein
desaster auf 300 milliarden helfen jetzt
bleibt abzuwarten der energiemarkt in
deutschland ist ruiniert ich spreche gar
nicht von der versorgungssicherheit mit
dem euro eine ruinierte weichwährung die
jedwede stabilität der deutschen demag
vergessen im september zieht von 8,9
milliarden euro durch inflation bei
sparguthaben aufgefressen worden das
sind auch opfer ihrer politik und hätte
sie kommen zum schlussbild kommt zum
schluss und soweit zeigt sich in diesem
haushalt aus sicht meiner fraktion ein
offenbarungseid meinen kollegen nicht
mittragen vielen dank
seit kurz erzählen diskutiert der
bundestag über den bundeshaushalt 20 22
wir hatten die einbringung durch den
bundesfinanzministers und danach begann
die allgemeine finanzdebatte die noch
eine weile weitergehen wird und in
dieser allgemeinen finanzdebatte wird
jetzt gleich sprechen raus aus der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und da
ist sie stellvertretende vorsitzende
[Applaus]
ich finde der vorliegende haushalt kann
sich wirklich sehen lassen das ist der
erste der ampel regierung
er unterscheidet sich nicht im volumen
von dem der vorgänger regierung aber
jetzt ist ein anderer inhalt drin meine
damen und herren dieser haushalt trägt
die ampeln an
besonders wichtig über 200 milliarden
euro für klimaschutz und
transformationen wird es in den
kommenden fünf jahren geben und ein
erstes umfangreiches entlastungs paket
von mehr als 16 milliarden euro darin
enthalten allein für dieses jahr der
einstieg in die kindergrundsicherung ein
kinder sofort zuschlag von 20 euro pro
kind pro monat für die ärmsten unserer
gesellschaft einen heizkostenzuschuss
von 270 euro einmal zuschlag
grundsicherung von 100 euro abschaffung
der eeg umlage zur senkung der
stromkosten erhöhung des steuerlichen
grundfreibetrags um 363 euro schon in
diesem jahr die verlängerung der home
office pauschale bis zum ende diesen
jahres und die anhebung des
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags um 200 euro
und eine ganze reihe weiterer maßnahmen
ich finde für den einstieg ist es
wirklich gut da silva
aber wahr ist auch
heute am 27 tags dieses furchtbaren
angriffskrieges von putin auf die
ukraine dieser krieg der findet nicht
nur unmittelbar an unsere eu
außengrenzen und unserer nato bündnis
grenze statt er fordert uns nicht nur
moralisch und fordert nicht nur unsere
solidarität durch waffenlieferungen
durch aufnahme von flüchtenden durch die
stärkung unserer bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit er stellt auch
uns jetzt hier heute auch schon vor
existenziellen herausforderungen
das hat die debatte um die beschlossenen
wirtschafts und finanzsanktionen gegen
russland bereits gezeigt ritter minister
harbeck und das ganze wirtschaft und
klima ministerium arbeitet mit hochdruck
daran uns von den fossilen energien
unabhängig zu machen mit dem so
genannten oster paket um dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren zu verdreifachen um die
energieversorgungssicherheit zu
verbessern um den energieverbrauch durch
ein ganzes bündel an effekte
energieeffizienz maßnahmen zu senken
denn jede einzelne eingesparte
kilowattstunde hilft meine damen und
herren
aber was jahrelang versäumt wurde wehrte
kollegen von der untere und ich sage nur
zehn tage regelung für windkraftanlagen
nord stream 2 verkauft der gasspeicher
also das jahrelang versand versäumt
wurde das kann selbst ein grüner
wirtschaftsminister nicht in wochen
ungeschehen machen mal damit
und schiesst wie eben die gaspreise
derzeit durch die decke obwohl im moment
sogar mehr erdgas geliefert wird als vor
dem krieg und auch die ölpreise waren
zwischenzeitlich auf einem allzeithoch
auch wenn sie inzwischen wieder auf
unter 100 dollar pro barrel gefallen
sind es ist gut dass das kartellamt
jetzt trifft spritpreise überprüft und
auch die gaspreise gehören auf den
prüfstand denn es wäre klimapolitisch
verheerend wenn putins krieg jetzt
riesige chris gewinne in alle fossilen
energie unternehmen spülen würde und
ihnen damit ein letztes aufbäumen
ermöglichen würde nein jetzt 24 der
größten mineralölkonzernen der welt
sitzen derzeit auf 9000 ungenutzten
förderlizenzen die sich plötzlich alle
wieder lohnen könnten angesichts der
astronomischen preise und das darf nicht
passieren meine damen und herren
und deswegen
er hat auch die einführung einer lieber
gewinn steuer und jeder vorschlag der
geeignet ist diese oligopole wie den up
zu stolz um auf den tisch meine damen
und herren
und wir brauchen ein weiteres großes
entlastungspaket es muss sozial
ausgewogen sein es muss effektiv sein
und das muss nachhaltig sein denn anders
ist für die vielen die dort der
drastische energiepreis stieg anstieg
und auch der anstieg bei nahrungsmittel
nicht zu stemmen und deswegen arbeitet
diese koalition mit hochdruck daran in
diesen stunden dieses paket fertig zu
schnüren denn es gibt schon jetzt
schätzungen dass die inflationsrate
allein wegen der gaspreise um 2,1
prozent zusätzlich steigen wird in
diesem jahr insgesamt könnte die sowieso
auf sieben prozent steigen und bei einem
gab embargo da würde die inflation wohl
zumindest kurzfristig sogar mindestens
zweistellig werden und angesichts dieser
großen unsicherheit sind wir gut beraten
mit augenmaß aufforderungen zu reagieren
aber eben finanzpolitisch auf messen und
nicht dogmatisch
und dabei kann man sicher uns jedenfalls
auf eines verlassen wir halten uns an
die gesetze der mathematik leider anders
als die cdu die cdu fordert der energie
liefern embargo jetzt
spritpreis bremse mindestens 40 cent pro
liter muss entlastet werden ersparen im
morgenmagazin gleichzeitig natürlich
keine neuen schulden das ist voodoo das
ist unseriös und ich würde mich wirklich
freuen wenn diese union weil wieder
politik macht die man ganz nehmen kann
mal da und
[Applaus]
mit dem vorliegenden haushalt und auch
mit dem ergänzt ins haushalt mit
weiteren maßnahmen werden wir jedenfalls
in dieser schweren zeit
putin klar entgegentreten und unseren
beitrag damit liefern dass wir
hoffentlich bald wieder eine friedliche
zukunft ermöglichen herzlichen dank
die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen im
deutschen bundestag lisa paus hier in
der allgemeinen finanzdebatte im
deutschen bundestag
damit
spreche hier eine debatte dass es
christian görke ist der sprecher für
finanzpolitik der linksfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau post ja dieser außer kann sich
wirklich sehen lassen dieser erste ampel
haushalt ist an trickserei kaum zu
überbieten indem sie einfach mal 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr sogar
an der schuldenbremse vorbeischleusen
und liebe kollegen kollegen der fdp
waren nicht gerade sie die immer für
eine ehrliche haushaltspolitik gestanden
haben während sie heute in der
opposition wären sie die ersten auf der
barrikade und ihr damals
fraktionsvorsitzender würde dann doch
noch ganz vorne dabei sein meine damen
und herren
sie wissen alle es ist ehrlicher
anzuerkennen dass die schuldenbremse
eine investitionsbremse ist denn jeder
der ein bisschen ahnung vom haushalt hat
und 1 und 1 zusammenzählen kann sieht
dass sie überbucht sind und deshalb wenn
sie schon ans grundgesetz geben meine
damen und herren dann nicht mit einem
neuen staschen spieler tricks sondern
für eine ehrliche reform bei der
schuldenbremse und unsere vorschläge für
eine goldene regel liegen auf dem tisch
und noch was herr kollege kindler sie
haben mir das jahrzehnt der investition
ausgerufen im finanzplan findet man das
nur bedingt selbst ihr angebliches 200
milliarden paket ist voller nebelkerzen
ich rechne dass ihnen mal gerne vor in
dieser legislatur sind bis 25 rund 160
milliarden für den klima funk vorgesehen
100 millionen hatte selbst noch die
desolate kroko da eingeplant macht ein
plus von 60 milliarden aber vorsicht aus
dem topf wird ja für die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage ja auch noch etwas in dem das
heißt also 23 milliarden wir sind auch
noch aus buchen bleiben sagen und
schreibe neun milliarden euro 9
milliarden euro pro jahr für klima
investitionen im haushalt meine damen
und herren das ist viel zu wenig zum
vergleich zum und bei den bundeswehr-
milliarden plus regulären
verteidigungshaushalt ergeben sich sogar
bis 2025 300 milliarden euro
das heißt sie geben für verteidigung
doppelt so viel aus wie für den
klimaschutz meine damen und herren das
sind bittere befunde und die werden wir
als linke korrigieren hier lag
bisher gerne hier ist mit einem
kompliment allerdings doch ein
vergiftetes komplimente wie viel hier in
diesem haushalt getrickst werde die fdp
spricht jetzt beginnt die provision als
erster haushaltspolitisch gestrichen
frau vizepräsident meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
kollegen es sind zeiten der not und
obwohl ich nun seit 20 jahren haushalte
begleite gemeinsam mit der kollegin
hagedorn und der kollegin lösch diese
situation haben wir noch nicht und das
sollten wir alle und deswegen möchte ich
auch mehr allgemeine äußerungen machen
das sollten wir alle auch
berücksichtigen wir müssen das als
koalition berücksichtigen dass wir hier
sehen müssen dass wir von manchen lieb
gewordenen uns gegenwärtig in zeiten der
not retten müssen wir müssen das aber
auch als opposition sehen wo die
jeweilige verantwortung ist ich sage
dass bittend in richtung cdu csu am ende
wird man euch nicht daran messen wie
viel ihr an kritik und sei sie auch noch
so unberechtigt und effektiv gewesen
messen sollen wird euch daran messen wie
viel verantwortung übernommen habe und
ich bitte ich bitte die cdu/csu deswegen
diese verantwortung auch nachzukommen
weil ich auch weiß dass in den letzten
jahrzehnten eine staatstragende partei
war und es auch weiterhin sein will und
wie ich glaube auch sein wird meine
damen und herren
wir haben eine sondersituation nicht nur
durch den angriffskrieg wir haben sie
immer noch durch die ausklingende
pandemie wir haben sie auch durch die
inflation die wir schon vor diesen krieg
hatten und wir werden mit all diesen
dingen als koalition in den
verhandlungen der haushaltsverhandlungen
zurande kommen müssen und hier im hause
ist noch keiner der weiß wenn wir im mai
juni abschließen wie die welt sich
entwickelt hat und keiner hier sollte
jetzt behaupten dass er schon genau
wisse was in einem solchen ergänzungs
haushalt stehen müsse oder stehen könnte
aber und das sage ich in richtung der
regierungsbank es muss dem
haushaltsausschuss und damit auch dem
parlament die möglichkeit gegeben werden
den ergänzungs haushalt so behandeln zu
können dass die parlamentsrechte gewahrt
werden können und dass wir dafür sorgen
dass wir am ende einen vernünftigen
haushalt haben da glaube ich aber und so
habe ich auch den minister verstanden
ist das ziel gegeben und kollege hasen
vor allen dingen kundige dobrindt kurz
direkt zum ergänzungs haushalt wenn sie
hier behaupten dass das was neues also
erstens 2020 haben wir das und kollege
dobrindt da muss ich schon sagen ich
glaube sie werden wenn sie nach hause
nach bayern kommen ärger kriegen der
erste minister der einen ergänzungs
haushalt nach 32 bundeshaushaltsordnung
gemacht hat war ein gewisser franz josef
strauß ich weiß 14 kennen aber das ist
jemand der in der csu mal ziemlich viel
gesagt hat und auch manchmal dinge
gemacht hat wo er über die wer die
verantwortung über die partei gestellt
hat vielleicht noch mal nachlesen und
nicht dinge behaupten die einfach an der
stelle nicht stimmen meine damen und
herren
es wird auf uns alle in den kommenden
monaten eine mammut aufgaben im
haushaltsverfahren zu kommen denn ab dem
moment wurde er aus einem parlament ist
liegt bei uns auch die arbeit und die
verantwortung den haushalt so passend zu
machen wie er denn dann auch notwendig
sein wird und auch das sage ich dann
wieder in hoffentlich verbindlicher
weise in richtung cdu csu dann hören wir
gerne jeden
kürzungsvorschlag der cdu/csu jeden sie
können das machen sie können sich ein
beispiel an der der opposition der fdp
in der letzten legislatur nehmen wir
haben 500 vorschläge po legislatur
gemacht sie sind eine viel größere
fraktion ich erwarte von ihnen
wenigstens das konkretisieren sie wo sie
sagen hier würde die cdu/csu einsparen
machen sie das wenn das verfahren kommt
sie haben es noch nicht gemacht weil es
überhaupt noch gar kein verfahren an der
stelle in diesem jahr gegeben hat und
dann schauen wir uns das sagen und ich
sage das für die koalition da wo es
vernünftig ist es gut und um das dann
auch deutlich zu sagen dass das nicht
nur etwas ist was in richtung cdu csu
sage sondern das sage ich auch in
richtung bundesregierung und ich bitte
die leider nicht mehr vollständig
anwesenden parlamentarischen
staatssekretären dass ihre ministerinnen
und ministern auch weiterzugeben
ich erwarte schon dass man noch weiter
schaut was denn da im haushalt im
eigenen ist was in den letzten 16 jahren
vielleicht nur noch deswegen da stand
war die cdu jeweils an der regierung war
ich bitte auch dass sie da noch mehr im
hause in sich gehen und sagen jetzt wo
wir diese notsituation bedingt durch den
ukraine krieg haben auf was können wir
auf was sollen wir aber insbesondere auf
was müssen wir verzichten damit dieses
parlament einen vernünftigen haushalt
beschließen kann meine damen und herren
zum sondervermögen will ich nur auf
eines hinweisen so hatte ich auch den
bundeskanzler hier verstanden wir haben
auf der einen seite das sondervermögen
und wir haben auf der anderen seite dass
zwei prozent ziel 1 2 prozent zielt das
übrigens die cdu/csu mit immer als das
richtige ziel gemacht und ich gestehe
sie war auch immer diejenigen die
stärker gedrängt hat die
verteidigungsausgaben in den letzten
jahren hochzufahren da werden sie von
mir auch nicht irgendwas anderes wenn
aber wenn das so ist und bei ihnen
damals die begründung war die zwei
prozent dann muss doch logischerweise
auch es so sein dass die 2 prozent die
basis dessen sind wofür die 100
milliarden dienen und dann müssen wir
darüber reden wie wir das unter diese
zwei prozent regel bekommen was wir an
zusätzlichen möglichkeiten dringend
benötigen letzten zwei sätze zum thema
sozialstaat weil immer gedacht wird die
fdp kümmert sich da nicht ruht der
finanzminister kümmert sich nicht darum
wir haben in 20 22 nach gegenwärtigen
plan 50,8 prozent sozialausgaben quote
sie steigt auf 51,9 am ende der
finanzplanung und liegt damit über
demjenigen was wir in 20 19 49,6 hatten
und das ist das wo sich auch zeigt auf
soziale verantwortung ist grundsätzlich
gilt aber ich schliesse wie immer mit
shakespeare polonius hamlets 110 3 sich
und dem freund verliert das darlehen oft
und morgen stumpft der wirtschafts
spitze ab und das wollen wir ja nicht
[Applaus]
bitte ich die blieben schluss 1 1 schon
einzupreisen in die redezeit
bundestags vizepräsidentin petra pau
erinnert hier an die redezeit das ist
jetzt bei den heutigen tage besonders
wichtig denn viele aus dem präsidium hat
es corona und deswegen muss sich petra
pau mit ihrer kollegin katrin göring
eckardt die schichten hierauf teilen
also lange arbeitstage für die beiden
bundestags vizepräsidentinnen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ja
wir sehen uns konfrontiert mit
außergewöhnlichen politischen
gesellschaftlichen herausforderungen
auch mit finanz und haushaltspolitischen
herausforderungen die pandemie folge
weiterhin wir haben viel geld
mobilisiert in dieser notsituation für
wirtschaftshilfen für direktzahlungen
wie den kinderbonus und die gute
nachricht wir setzen viele maßnahmen mit
dem vierten kroner steuer hilfe gesetz
ford beispielsweise die verlängerung der
steuerfreiheit für arbeitgeber zuschüsse
zum kurzarbeitergeld das ist ein gutes
signal diese ampel regierung dass wir
die hilfsleistungen auch fortsetzung
eines teils der stelle klargestellt in
dem anime hat sich gezeigt wie wichtig
ein starker ein handlungsfähiger staat
ist und dass weder auch in zukunft sein
müssen für die anstehenden neuen
herausforderungen dafür sorgen wir auch
mit diesem haushalt meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
ich kann nicht mit shakespeare ihnen ich
kann mit willy brandt dienen der gesagt
jede zeit will herr finanzminister
eigene antworten
und man muss dazu auf der höhe der zeit
sein ich habe das gefühl dass manche
oppositionspartei sich schwer tut gerade
auf der höhe der zeit zu sein und auch
die richtigen antworten zu geben wir
müssen das wir wollen das auch vor uns
liegen große aufgaben und wir müssen die
finanzierung auch in bekommen zentrale
herausforderung ist das thema
klimaschutz die herausforderungen hier
und die antwort darauf geben wir die
laute dämonisieren viel geld mit dem
klima an transformations- fonds wir
begegnen damit der wirtschaftskrise in
dem wir massive investitionen in die
digitalisierung in den klimaschutz in
die erneuerbaren energien ermöglichen
und bringen dann wirtschaftliche
prosperität wir bringen neue
arbeitsplätze und klimaschutz zusammen
das ist ein sehr konstruktiver vorschlag
um mit dieser krise umzugehen und ich
würde mir wünschen von seiten der union
dass sie ebenso konstruktiv an der
ausgestaltung dieses klima an
transformationsphase angehen und nicht
gegen dieses wichtige instrument klaren
das wäre eine konstruktive opposition
haltung an dieser stelle meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
und werden uns die neue
sicherheitslage bedeutet ein noch
schwierigeres
wirtschafts und finanzpolitisches umfeld
und natürlich auch mehrausgaben
einerseits für humanitäre hilfe für die
aufnahme derjenigen die es aus dem
kriegsgebiet flüchten aber natürlich
auch für die bessere ausrüstung
unserer bundeswehr auch hier geben wir
eine antwort in dieser zeit eine
passende antwort und das ist das
sondervermögen über 100 milliarden euro
für die bessere ausrüstung der
bundeswehr auch hier gilt diese große
herausforderung bedarf auch der
konstruktiven beteiligung durch die
opposition ich habe jetzt heute nur
gehört dass sie kritisieren sie
kritisieren den klima transformations-
vor sie kritisieren dass zu einer
milliarden sondervermögen nennen es
ist eine notwendige ausrüstung und
notwendige investition in die zukunft in
die bundeswehr das ist nicht teuer
sondern richtig und notwendig und ich
habe keinen einzigen vorschlag gehört
wie wir das anders tun sollen ich würde
mir erwarten dass dann etwas kommt kein
sondervermögen keine hohe und steuern
dann geht es um bundes werden sagen es
wird alles beim alten wir wollen das
nicht auch sie sollten sich konstruktive
debatte beteiligen meine sehr geehrten
oder nicht alle vorschläge in aktuelle
debatten hilfreich sie müssen wissen
dass die senkung der mehrwertsteuer auf
dem spritpreise wird eu-recht nicht
vereinbar ist auch vor allen dingen
müssten sie wissen dass gleichzeitig ihr
vorschlag bedeutet dass die
energielieferanten die mit
spekulationsgetrieben hohen preisen nun
hohe gewinne machen
zusätzlich sie entlasten wollen mit
dieser maßnahme denn es gibt
mitnahmeeffekte aber teils senkung der
preise an der tankstelle auch das muss
man sagen wir werden mit dem
steuerentlastungsgesetz
gezielt menschen entlasten die lage
versetzen diese zusätzlichen belastung
ich sie haben auch zu tragen und
grundfreibetrag hat der finanzminister
schon erwähnt auch mit der erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale auch da geben wir die
richtigen antworten auf der höhe der
zeit um den menschen zu helfen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren und wir
werden auch antworten finden müssen
dafür auf der einnahmenseite auch besser
zu werden ich nenne nur ein thema das im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben
nämlich steuerbetrug beispielsweise bei
der umsatzsteuer zu bekämpfen das
brächte einen niedrigen zweistelligen
milliarden betrag den wir da hin
bekommen wollen und eins ist klar wir
wollen und wir müssen die vorhaben die
wir vereinbart haben gerade um den
sozialen zusammenhalt zu stärken gerade
auch in dieser krise zu stärken dass wir
die auch weiter stemmen wollen und
müssen wir wollen der wohnungen haben
wir wollen die kindergrundsicherung wir
wollen mehr in die bildung investieren
und auch da
werden wir sicherlich dann weitere
wichtige und neue antworten auf der höhe
der zeit finden ich freue mich auf die
weiteren beratungen
mutterschiff der fdp wirkt hier auch für
eine konstruktive zusammenarbeit aber
auch das ist nichts ungewöhnliches bei
koalitionsfraktionen wenn sie denn einen
haushaltsentwurf vorlegen
uli hoeneß spricht jetzt für bündnis
90/die grünen er sitzt im
haushaltsausschuss und das hier ist
seine erste rede
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen die herausforderungen für
diese junge regierungskoalition könnten
kaum größer sein die korona situation
bleibt kritisch der gesundheitsschutz
und die nachhaltige erholung der
wirtschaft bindemittel und doch unsere
aufmerksamkeit fokussiert sich auf die
schreckliche situation in der ukraine im
angesicht des krieges sind wir alle in
der pflicht alte überzeugungen zu
überdenken
scheinbaren gewissheiten zu verwerfen
das geht natürlich auch für unsere
haushaltspolitik liebe kolleginnen der
vorliegende haushaltsentwurf trägt
diesen grundsatz in weiten teilen
rechnung
die bundesregierung kommt ihrer
internationalen verantwortung nach
stellt unter anderem eine milliarde euro
bereit für maßnahmen der humanitären
hilfe für die krisenbewältigung und
unterstützen die ukraine direkt
finanziell gemeinsam mit unseren
europäischen partnern weil es unsere
verdammte verantwortung ist und ja
wir spüren die konsequenzen des krieges
auch hier in deutschland steigende
energiepreise die fossile inflation und
auch an der supermarktkasse wird es
teurer und deswegen liebe kolleginnen
kollegen ist es richtig dass wir weit
reichende entlastungsmaßnahmen auf den
weg gebracht haben die jetzt auch im
haushalt abgebildet sind unter anderem
der kinder sofort zuschlag als wichtiger
schritt hin zur kindergrundsicherung mit
der kinderarmut endlich wirksam
bekämpfen werden wir machen uns auf den
weg für mehr chancengerechtigkeit und
das ist gut so liebe kollegin collien
es aber auch dabei darf es nicht bleiben
wir müssen den ergänzungs haushalt jetzt
nutzen um weitere spürbare entlastungen
zu finanzieren die zeit ist reif jetzt
für das energie geld entlass entlastet
alle gerade kleine und mittlere
einkommen familien im besonderen maße
darum muss es jetzt gehen ein tank
rabatt kann das nicht leisten liebe
kollegen und verließ
lassen sie mich einige kennzahlen aus
diesem entwurf noch mal heraus greifen
allein im kernhaushalt
50,8 milliarden investitionen in diesem
jahr verstetigt über die kommenden jahre
das ist ein rekordniveau im vergleich zu
vor corinna zeit und das sind eben
investitionen in die zukunft 30,4
milliarden im gesamtentwurf für bildung
und forschung den jahren für
digitalisierung und innovation 27,8
milliarden programm ausgaben aus dem
energie und klimafonds für die
klimaneutrale transformation und ja
endlich schaffen wir es mehr in die
schiene als in die straße zu investieren
auch wenn hier noch deutlich mehr gehen
muss für eine ernsthafte und nachhaltige
mobilität zu ende
der
regierungsentwurf ist ein gutes
zwischenergebnis für mehr chancen und
generationengerechtigkeit und das ist
auch dringend nötig nach 16 jahren
unionsgeführter verwaltung des status
quo auf kosten der künftigen generation
aber
der haushalt muss eben auch im kontext
der aktuellen umstände bewertet werden
er wird gedehnt durch notwendige
ausgaben der äußeren inneren sicherheit
und für den zivilschutz der im
parlamentarischen verfahren jetzt noch
mal gestärkt werden sollte es wäre
falsch dringend notwendige maßnahmen vom
massiven ausbau der erneuerbaren energie
über flüchtlings bezogene ausgaben bis
hin zu sozialen unterstützungsmaßnahmen
jetzt aber eben auch künftig
konservativen haushalts dogmen zu
unterwerfen das wäre unverantwortlich
dass adressiert eben nicht die realität
und das ist doch nicht nachhaltig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich sagte es bereits viele scheinbaren
gewissheiten sind im angesicht der
aktuellen ereignisse überholt aber
mindestens eine gewissheit bleibt und
bei unter umständen in den letzten
wochen ein anderer ein falscher eindruck
entstanden ist möchte ich mit dieser
gewissheit ausschließen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen haushaltsrecht
ist parlaments recht der bundeshaushalt
wird hier beschlossen hier in der
herzkammer der demokratie hier im
deutschen bundestag und in diesem sinne
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wünsche
ich uns konstruktive aber eben vor allem
auch selbstbewusster parlamentarische
beratungen herzlichen dank
und damit der zuvor letzte rednerin in
dieser debatte antje tillmann ist die
sprecherin der finanzen der
unionsfraktion hier schon im bild die
muss natürlich noch warten bis hier das
pult desinfiziert wird unter dem glas
herstellen heute nun die kollegin antje
tillmann das macht
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte damen und herren
herr minister lindner sie mussten heute
sehr tapfer sein einer ihrer lieblings
setzte dieser tage ist die
schuldenbremse ist keine politische
entscheidung sondern eine vorgabe der
verfassung das ist so ein bisschen wie
das singen im dunkeln denn alle anderen
reden ihrer anderen koalitionspartner
haben damit nichts zu tun
sie selber
die selber halten im kernhaushalt die
schuldenbremse schon nicht ein denn die
es durch corona maßnahmen bedingt und
sie wissen sehr genau dass
personalkosten erhöhung und straßenbau
mit corona überhaupt nichts zu tun haben
sie haben ganz verschämt angekündigt
dass der ergänzungs haushalt durch eine
ausweitung der schulden notlage regelung
ukraine krieg erweitert werden soll ich
bin gespannt wann sie offiziell mit
diesem vorschlag kommen dass sie eine
neue notlage verkünden wollen und ich
bin auch gespannt ob sie dann die zweite
regelungen einhalten dass sie dann
nämlich mit dem ergänzungs haushalt auf
einen tilgungsplan vorlegen müssen und
nein herr kollege das energie geld ist
nämlich dann nicht auf diesem energien
zum haushalt zu finanzieren das wäre
ganz klar verfassungswidrig all die
wünsche geäußert worden sind können im
ergänzungs haushalt nicht mehr
untergebracht werden wenn die notlage
mit dem ukraine krieg begründet wird und
ansonsten ist es nicht finanzierbar und
der minister ich bin sicher sie werden
mit dem ergänzungs haushalt auch eine
berichtigung vorliegen ihrer wäsche
wachstumsprognose 3,6 prozent planen die
1 ich bin sicher sie werden mit dem
ergänzungs haushalt ungefähr zehn
milliarden euro einsparen müssten im
haushalt enthalten
die degressive abschreibung
verlustverrechnung home office pauschale
wir begrüßen das ausdrücklich wobei der
erlass tungs entlastungseffekt nicht
sehr groß ist denn tatsächlich handelt
es sich um gewinnverschiebungen die home
office pauschale geht fast immer im
werbungskostenpauschbetrag unter
anders als sie gesagt haben ist das
steuerentlastungspaket eben nicht im
haushalt eingepreist jedenfalls nicht
als steuerentlastungspaket sie haben
über eine globale mindereinnahme 3,8
milliarden euro zur verfügung gestellt
1,98 das steuerentlastungspaket schon
aus liebe kollegin kollegen dankbar die
aktion sie wissen dann dieser haushalt
hat noch spielraum von 1,9 milliarden
euro und damit werden sie absolut nichts
aus ihrem koalitionsvertrag finanzieren
können und wenn ich mir dann an konnte
man sie einzeln im haushalt stehen haben
grundfreibetrags erhöhung sie lassen
sich feiern für 4,7 milliarden euro
entlastung davon sind 3 milliarden der
grundfreibetrag der grundfreibetrag es
verfassungsrechtlich geboten übrig
bleibt die fernpendler pauschale von 300
millionen und der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag von 1.000.000
und es ist immer gut arbeitnehmer zu
entlasten aber warum sie diejenigen die
keine zusätzlichen kosten haben mit 1,1
millionen entlasten das ist nämlich der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag und diejenigen
die an der tankstelle nicht mehr
weiterwissen mit 300 millionen abspeisen
dass es ihr geheimnis was sie uns
vielleicht in den haushaltsberatungen
weiter erklärt werden sie verabschieden
sich mit diesem haushalt und das muss
ihnen klar sein liebe koalitionäre von
allem was sie im koalitionsvertrag
stehen haben kindergrundsicherung liebe
kollegin pause es kann doch nicht ihr
ernst sein dass die kindergrundsicherung
20 euro ausmacht da waren wir ja doppelt
so gut ohne kindergrundsicherung
bürgergeld nicht kommen energie gelten
ich kommen super abschreibungen ich
komme mal ganz abgesehen von
thesaurierung begünstigend allem sie
haben diesen haushalten die
mittelfristige finanzplanung bis auf den
letzten euro ausgelaugt sie haben
gerechnet mit 3,6 wachstum jetzt und 2,3
im nächsten jahr sieht werden keine
zusätzlichen einnahmen haben und damit
verabschiedeten sie sich direkt mit
ihrem haushalt von ihren pool aktions
vorstellungen der rest der legislatur
kann für sie eigentlich nur noch traurig
enden danke
[Applaus]
zu ihrer ersten rede im deutschen
bundestag hat nun die kollegin frauke
heiligenstadt will die spd
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau thema ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
bei der rede die sie gerade gehalten
haben in welchem haushaltsplan sie
reingeguckt haben ob den für dieses jahr
oder für das letzte jahr oder wann auch
immer der bundesfinanzminister hat einen
haushalt für das jahr 2022 vorgelegt der
zum einen ein kurs der soliden
finanzpolitik darlegt und zum anderen
notwendige weichen für wichtige
zukunftsprojekte darstellt
damit mit diesem haushalt vorgelegt wird
fortschritt möglich und unser land wird
sicher durch sehr schwierige zeiten
geführt
was heißt fortschritt in der zukunft im
finanzpolitischen gebrauch zukunft heißt
zum beispiel notwendige investitionen
beim klimaschutz bei der digitalisierung
bei der forschung und bei der bildung in
der infrastruktur wir haben zahlreiche
vorstellungen hier eben gerade in der
debatte gehört denn nur so gelingt ein
umbau zu einem klimaneutral und
digitalen gemeinwesen zu einer guten
volkswirtschaft in unserem land in
zahlen ausgedrückt heißt das
200 milliarden euro mehr für klimaschutz
und damit für eine nachhaltige
wirtschaftliche entwicklung das ist gute
politik meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren
so können zum beispiel co2 neutrale
produktionsverfahren entwickelt werden
oder klimafreundliche produkte
entwickelt werden gleichzeitig wissen
wir dass dringend investitionen im
bereich der bildung und der
digitalisierung notwendig sind deswegen
hat zb auch das bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung hier vier
milliarden euro mehr geld zur verfügung
in diesem jahr das ist gut für die
bildung für die forschung und für die
menschen in unserem land meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
zu punkt eben der finanzpolitik heißt
für meine fraktion aber auch dass
bürgerinnen und bürger in dieser
schwierigen situation nicht im stich
gelassen werden deshalb haben wir als
koalition 1 16 milliarden euro
entlastungs paket beschlossen das bringt
für viele menschen in unserem land eine
spürbare entlastung nicht nur ein
bisschen sehr geehrte frau kümmern
nachdem bereits im letzten plenum
beschlossenen heizkostenzuschuss und dem
beschluss über die verlängerung der
sonderregelung beim kurzarbeitergeld
enthält das entlastungspaket noch
zahlreiche einzelmaßnahmen meine
kolleginnen und kollegen haben das sehr
häufig schon erwähnt die abschaffen wir
ziehen die abschaffung der eeg-umlage
vor das entlastet 1 2 einen vierköpfigen
haushalt um 300 euro im jahr das ist
doch etwas oder wir werden den
arbeitnehmer pauschbetrag erhöhen auch
1200 euro den grundfreibetrag für die
einkommensteuer die fern
pendlerpauschale auf 38 cent pro
kilometer oder wir haben menschen hilfe
bezug 100 euro sofort zuschlag gegeben
und der entsprechenden zuschlag für die
kinder die von armut bedroht sind es
auch schon mehrfach heute hier erwähnt
worden
das ist soziale politik in zahlen
gegossen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren und das dahinter steht die spd
fraktion
nebenbei
zusätzlich reagieren wir mit dem
haushaltsentwurf auf dem krieg der
ukraine denn der ist jetzt tatsächlich
auch
wichtig und in unserem weiteren
wirtschaftlichen bemühen und
finanzierungs bemühen zu hinterlegen so
haben wir eine milliarde euro für
humanitäre hilfe zu erwarten denn wir
wissen noch nicht was auf uns zukommt
mir ist dabei besonders wichtig dass der
bund die länder und die kommunen bei der
unterbringung der geflüchteten nicht im
stich lassen wird es gibt bereits eine
arbeitsgruppe aus bund und
ländervertretern die sich mit der
problematik beschäftigen werden und die
zügig ergebnisse vorlegen wird der bund
wird für diese aufgaben an der seite der
länder und kommunen stehen meine sehr
verehrten damen und ja das ist wichtig
und ganzes nachhaltig
wir wissen ich liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen welche auswirkungen dieser
fürchterliche angriffskrieg putins noch
auf unser land haben wird gleichzeitig
sind wir aber zur hilfeleistung
verpflichtet und wir werden dieser
selbstverständlich nachkommen der
koalition ist es aber wichtig daneben
auch die zukunftsprojekte auf den weg zu
bringen und die entscheidenden
weichenstellungen mit diesem haushalt
vorzunehmen das ist mit diesem entwurf
bereits gelungen deshalb geht man dank
auch an dem bundesfinanzminister und an
die mitarbeitenden in den ministerien
den entsprechenden häusern die betroffen
sind es ist keine einfache zeit meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren aber wir
krempeln die arme ärmel hoch wir packen
die aufgaben an wir werden das mit
gemeinsamkeit und mit einem blick für
die zukunft auch schaffen vielen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit
das war also die allgemeine
finanzdebatte hier zum
21 und zum finanzplan des bundes